neuf ans qu'on court après une
autorisation pour la délocalisation de
ce magasin pour la reconstruction
et puis bon ça n'en finit pas d'aboutir
c'est la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase
ce supermarché doit être transférée à un
endroit plus urbanisée à l'autre bout de
châteaumeillant mais le maire et suit un
énième refus et baissent les bras d'un
côté on veut on vous aide pour
revitaliser de l'autre côté on vous
supprime les services à la population
c'est complètement incohérent car il est
là le fond du problème
il y a cinq ans le centre ville avait
été au coeur d'un projet de
revitalisation
mais depuis les services publics
disparaissent et les dotations de l'état
baisse c'en est trop pour ce maire guy
bergeron est à bout il jette les push
pied comme les chèques mensuels
effectivement très très difficile parce
que vivre ces situations là je sais que
c'est pas normal c'est pas normal
aujourd'hui qu' on est autant août on
dit respect à ce que finalement c'est ça
d'autant dire respect pour les mères à
la fin à la fin d'un mandat
on vous balance ça comme ça on vous
supprime tels services tels services
depuis que j'ai pris cette décision je
curieusement je me sens je me sens mieux
parce que je vous raconte pas les nuits
d'insomnie
dans notre situation qui semble qu'ils
sont compliquées au coeur du village
c'est l'un des principaux sujets de
discussion habitants et commerçants le
soutiennent je pense que la raison pour
certains points que tous en bas qui ne
peut rien que voilà c'est tout de par
ses fonctions c'est un homme qui est
très engagée pour sa commune qui vit
vraiment avec ses tripes et au vu de ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans le village
je pense qu'il a complètement raison
je le soutiens fou nous avons eu un
maire ça fait cinquante et un ans que je
suis commerçante à châteaulin donc c'est
tout je sais de quoi je parle
à travers sa démission dit bergerot
souhaite faire passer un message celui
d'un malaise profond que rencontrent les
maires ruraux qui ne tient pas de vagues
et adam